bonjour maximum actuel je suis le gérant
des magasins cash converters nous sommes
une jeune pme avec 35 salariés le
premier magasin ouvert en 2010 à 5 pts
il a suivi celui de savannah à saint
paul puis celui de saint-andré où nous
sommes aujourd'hui et enfin celui qui
vient juste d'ouvrir à saint-pierre le 6
septembre à la vente qu'est-ce que cash
converters c'était des magasins d'achat
et de vente de matériel d'occasion nous
achetons l'ensemble des produits sauf
les meubles et les vêtements donc de
l'informatique des jeux des consoles
de
de l'électroménager évidemment des
bijoux et nous les revendons au meilleur
prix avec une garantie
alors aujourd'hui nous recherchons un
acheteur vendeur sur le magasin de saint
paul alors qu'est ce que le métier
d'acheteur vendeur c'est d'acheter aux
particuliers l'ensemble des produits qui
peut nous ramener donc tout sauf les
meubles et vêtements ça passe de la
téléphonie mobile aux ordinateurs
portables en passant par
l'électroménager la musique là ici la
sono
les bijoux évidemment donc il ya une
connaissance produits importantes à
avoir mais également savoir tester le
produit pour vérifier qu'il fonctionne
bien et ensuite pouvoir le mettre à la
vente évidemment vous serez appelé aussi
à être vendeur donc à savoir vendre le
produit accueillir le client connaître
toutes les spécificités du magasin du
logiciel c'est un métier très
intéressant très complet si vous êtes
motivé et que ce poste vous intéresse
n'hésitez pas contactez nous
bonjour je m'appelle aussi ordinaires
logé 20 ans j'habite à saint denis je
recherche un emploi dans la vente de
locaux ps j'ai obtenu assez ap d'employé
de commerce multispécialités et
j'aimerais travailler en vente
par exemple dans les rayons de boissons
j'ai effectué pas mal de stages en
entreprise j'ai pu découvrir
des choses que je savais pas faire comme
fait à la mise en rayon fait le fascine
les types étage dépôt de palettes gérer
les stocks et je suis actuellement en
formation de garantie jeune formation de
la mission locale j'ai l'expérience dans
l'espace vert quand j'ai effectué
neuf mois de service civique à la villa
départementale au conseil général dans
la rue de paris voilà je suis souriant
je suis motivé dynamique
je recherche du travail actuellement
n'hésitez pas à me contacter je suis
prêt à donner le meilleur de moi même
bonjour je me présente je suis allée da
je recherche un emploi d'assistant de
direction secrétaire de direction
j'ai le permis je suis j'ai un vécu
légalement je suis dit je suis mobile
géographiquement
j'ai travaillé dans le secteur du
secrétariat jeter tenir les agendas je
vais recevoir le public j'ai réalisé la
gestion des courriers je sais utiliser
le logiciel microsoft office j'ai une
formation de bts action commerciale j'ai
également une licence aes donc
d'économies d'administration économique
et sociale et une licence en
administration économique et sociale on
puisse gérer récemment effectué un titre
à la fois de saint-andré en ccp
comptabilité au niveau de la paye donc
j'ai réactualisées toutes mes formations
et mes connaissances et j'espère que ma
candidature sera sélectionné
espère attirer votre attention
à travers cette émission
bonjour je m'appelle william klein j'ai
29 ans je recherche un en bas dans le
domaine de la restauration en page les
angles usines que ce soit en tant que
plongeur commis de cuisine ou de cuisine
j'ai le permis b et je suis exilé je
peux déplacer de la ville de
saint-gilles avoir un nom j'ai ainsi que
ph en hôtellerie restauration en tant
que commis cuisine qui est l'équivalent
d'un ca
pcf pro900 j'ai travaillé récemment
durant un an à l'as ptt de saint denis
auparavant j'ai travaillé pour que le
mène pendant une saison de ski ensuite
tu travaillé pendant un an et demi dans
la brasserie en tant que commune cuisine
j'aime bien travailler en équipe j'aime
bien raconte de belles choses découvrir
d'autres façons de travailler
mes hommes et passion sont le football
devait aider la cua ça fait jamais dispo
nature j'espère que ma candidature vous
a plu appelez moi à méru
contactez nous sur notre page facebook
www.facebook.com cela chauffe 7,4 tv ou
par téléphone 02 100 62 92 37 60
de 7 4 cv autre émission au service de
l'emploi à la réunion